[Music]
[Applause]
he's Joe flacko former Super Bowl MVP
you won a Corvette didn't you they gave
you a Corvette when you won the MVP they
did they they were still giving away
cars I'm not sure if they're doing that
but yeah where is that
Corvette man it's uh it's in a uh it's
in an old garage not not on the road
it's not street legal right now I don't
have it registered but it's in an old
garage in the house my brother's living
in right now wait wait it's not legal
it's not street legal what are we what
are we doing it's street it's street
legal I just don't have it registered
it's probably the tires are probably dry
rot it's it's it's probably not in the
best shape to be honest with you does it
say MVP anything that uh yeah you know
what there's like a little thing inside
of the car and where it has the VIN
number it says Joe Flaco Super Bowl MVP
oh cool cool clear up something what
were you doing before the Browns called
you were you doing what you're doing
right now sitting on the count yeah I
mean there was a little bit of that I
guess that's what everybody likes to say
but it was like an extended off season
um uh with hope that it was an extended
offseason like with hope that there was
going to be a signing at some point but
you just don't know if that's the case
but were you getting calls or making
calls no no neither um and there's
probably there was probably a point in
the offseason where my agent was making
calls and hoping to get calls but uh but
at that you know at a certain point
neither of those things were happening
but when Aaron Rogers goes
down nothing yeah I mean maybe my agent
had some conversations but not not not
not anything significant it wasn't like
we were like I said it wasn't I I'm sure
he reached out to teams throughout the
course of the season but it wasn't
like um you know I I feel like when
teams want you they're probably going to
to reach out to you uh you know and
obviously you want to do a little bit of
digging so that you make sure you're
giving yourself the best chance but it's
ultimately not not up to you what's the
first thing to go on a
quarterback oh man
uh I think quarterback's one of those
unique positions I I've talked about it
a lot recently because it is so it is so
oriented around um processing things
quickly and stuff like that that um
depending on your style of play
obviously um you can continue to to kind
of get better as as you age um obviously
there's a point in your career where
you're the most explosive you're
probably going to be and the most
athletic you're probably going to be um
but the the bottom line is is we don't
play you know we don't play at an age
where that really gets too crazy you
know in on on the downside but you're
not losing arm strength your arm
strength is the same as it's been yeah
yeah listen I think there was a there
was a point in my career where when I
was younger like even coming out in
college and coming out of college where
you're actively like you know you're
proud of the fact that you can throw the
ball far but that's not really what
makes a quarterback anyway you know even
if you can throw the ball 90 yards like
the most you throw the ball in a game is
55 yards 50 you know maybe 60 yards on
an off chance one game I can't even
imagine I've done that very many times
in my career it's more about being able
to control the ball and and be accurate
within that 30 yard 25 30 yard range so
I think the guys that honestly like I
think most guys that are at in the NFL
level have a have a sense of just
naturally being able to be good throwers
and I I I think that requires using your
whole body to to to do that so your arm
really doesn't take that that much of a
hit and I think no I I don't think arm
strength I mean I think most of the guys
that have played pretty long I mean you
can look at their arms I mean I think in
in some ways they get stronger from the
time they're 22 23 years old because
because you know as you get close to 30
you get stronger and I think you're able
to keep that pretty easily take me back
to April of
2012 New York Times article where you
said that uh you were the best
quarterback in the
NFL uh you know what I'm trying to
remember exact I feel like that was on a
radio show in Baltimore or something
like that where it was like okay you
know I was directly I was directly asked
the question you know and I it was funny
because I I just I was just talking to
somebody about this the other day like
of course you know of course of course I
am you know uh I I do like I I do that
with my kids just like you know it's
like I was talking to somebody up
recently I ask my kids all the time you
know and who who's the best and if
you're not going to believe it then
nobody's going to believe it and it's
all it's not about just just saying it
that's part of it but it's it's about
being in put in situations where you
have to overcome things and you start to
actually believe it and and you believe
it for good reason so I I was using it
in that context like I think it's
important that your kids have that
belief but it's important to put the put
them in situations where they have to
overcome difficult things so that they
have reason to actually believe it do
you think you're better than Brady and
Payton Manning right now listen man
those guys come on look at but right now
right now you're a better quarterback
than pton Manning
is listen I don't know about Brady I I I
I love this conversation but uh and and
and in a private room it would be a fun
conversation to have to have to have I
love having the conversation with those
guys um I'm not getting goated into
saying anything crazy those guys did you
just say goat you you were goat oh whoa
you just Joe flacko called himself the
goat
oh goed goated in okay I I could have
never imagined I don't think any of us
could have how long you were those guys
were going to be in the league I mean
obviously especially how long Tom was
goingon to be in the league and uh you
know I felt like there were some games
there where I we played in playoffs
against him and it was like okay he's
probably got you know another year or
two left but he just set the standard he
set the standard in so many different
ways um and not that that standard is
ever going to be reached by anybody else
you know it it's very hard to wrap your
head around a lot of the things that he
did and and like I said especially to be
if there is some off chance that
somebody comes and is able to do
anything close to what he's done I give
him a lot of credit a ton of credit
obviously but to be the first to do so
many different things and to kind of
like not really care about what other
people think and what's supposed to
happen and go out there and continue to
do the things he did is just so so
incredible I mean I think he is a guy
like you talk about arm strength and and
staying in shape I think he's a guy that
like you look at him and like he's in
better shape at the end of his career
and stronger physically like his arm got
somewhere in probably five six years in
the league it almost I don't know if his
arm actually did get stronger but it
looked like it did like he just did so
many incredible things we're talking to
Joe Flaco what's your status now do you
know where you're playing if you're
playing next year I don't I don't I mean
you know that you know I don't know that
uh uh listen I I um it's a typical
offseason I'm trying to get myself back
into it and it it's I feel so fortunate
to have been able to play you know for
two months as opposed to sitting here
right now and getting back into the
swing of things in the off season um and
never have and kind of looking back at
this season like man I you know I guess
I'm done I nobody gave me a call now to
have that feeling like okay I was able
to go out there and play and I I I think
I was able to show that I can still play
so now we'll see what happens this
offseason so I'm excited about kind of
the next couple months and what's going
to happen but would you be satisfied
being on a roster as opposed to being
being able to compete for the the
starting job right listen I I think it's
tough to talk about satisfied this and
satisfied that I
think you know there's part of you
that's never really satisfied no matter
what you know if you're a starter well
then you're not you're not satisfied
with you know
not winning every single game and it and
obviously like the last three years I've
been a backup and um obviously with
aspirations to play at some point and
I've been able to play some games uh
here and there but listen man once
you've played in this league and once
you've played Just football in general
like all of us want to play football um
so so so you're never going to be
satisfied with sitting around and
working hard and not really ever getting
an opportunity So Satisfied yeah you're
definitely not going to be that I think
you have to find you have to find ways
each day to kind of to kind of stay
focused and get yourself through those
time periods but you're never going to
be satisfied with not playing football
and that's that's not just me that's
everybody in the league I mean you look
at everybody probably from the outside
looks at backup quarterbacks and like
man that's a pretty good job you know
you get to make a couple million dollars
a year and you get to sit on the bench
watch the guy go it's not a good job man
it
sucks it's miserable you want to be
playing and not only that like you get
nervous before a game right like when
you play and you're the guy well you
know you're the guy and you go out there
and you're nervous before the game but
then this the ball snap and you go out
there and you have fun and you're just
in the moment when you're the backup
you're literally on the sideline every
single play like still dealing with
pregame Jitter pregame nerves you know
what I mean and you just never get rid
of them and then it's it's just not it's
not fun so like obviously not having to
do that for most of my career
you get to look at that position in a
little bit of a different way and for
those guys to the guys that you you do
look at the guys that come in mid game
or come in whenever they do and you
gotta give them credit it's not as easy
of a job as you want to make it out to
be and you're definitely you definitely
a part of that is the mental part where
we all want to be out there playing do
you think you're better than DeShaun
Watson come on man what are you doing
here uh listen Deshawn I I the thing
about Deshawn is you know I it'll be
nice for him to be able to stay healthy
uh for a full season and and and and get
that kind of um you know get a solid
foundation under his belt and things
like that I think we all have you know
we've all been able to see what what he
can do uh when he's able to be in there
for a full 16 17 game so by the way uh
Joe was named most handsome player in
the NFL uh that was fanatics did do you
remember that that did you get an award
for that but no you you were named the
most attractive player in the NFL in
January 2017 a survey by
Fanatics man I was goingon to say who
what what who did this who who voted on
this it was like like my wife that was
it that she was she was the only person
would she have voted for you as most
handsome though I yeah exactly that's a
good point she probably wouldn't have
Brady was still playing and grappolo was
in there
so did you get an award from Fanatics
for being the most attractive player in
the NFL I didn't I wish I got some free
stuff for my kids or something you know
how important is it that your kids get
to see Dad play I don't know if it's
important but man it is it is special
it's it's it's you know it's a unique
situation I remember I remember like I
think Matt St was walking out of the
locker room after games with like
Teenage Kids you know
it's
not it's just a unique experience and
you know it's not something that i' had
ever thought about doing like you think
about when you're a kid you think about
being an NFL quarterback or you know a
major league baseball player like you
can put yourself in those situations and
and think about how cool they would be
but part like having your kids watch you
do it that's not really a part of the
dream and and all that so even when I
started to have children it wasn't like
I was thinking about man it'd be cool to
have these guys watch me play but now
when you're in it and and you see how
into it they are and just they're at
that age where like they know everything
about you know professional sports it it
it's really cool when you got four or
five kids five wow yeah I think my
daughter's pretty my daughter's pretty
oblivious to to what's going on you know
besides wanting to run up and give me a
hug but you know but she's aware of
Taylor Swift and the Kansas City chief
yeah she's becoming more and more aware
of Taylor Swift but you know so she's a
momes fan fan yeah yeah yeah listen I
think she she's not quite there either
but she she's getting there listen you
can have worse worse worse Role Models I
mean I think she's done a pretty good
job for all the young girls out there
absolutely well good luck in the
offseason hopefully you don't stay on
the couch the entire time there Joe you
got it you got it thank you bud all
right man that's Joe flacko he's a Super
Bowl champ and won the MVP with the
Ravens in fact uh defeating Jim
Harbaugh's 49ers there